The following
content is provided
under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue
to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: I hope you're
all recovered from the quiz.
Our apologies for
hard questions,
but it's just the first quiz.
We have a lot more fun
things to do in 006.
So today's lecture today's
lecture is a light lecture,
I would even call it a
recreational mathematics
lecture.
And so, thanks for coming.
I'll make it worth
your while, all right?
So we're going to talk
about irrationals.
The motivation behind
this is really that every
once in awhile we are going
to have a situation where
we want to compute with numbers
that are much longer than 64
bits, which is really the word
length in standard computer
these days.
It used to be 8 bits
back in the day.
For most of my adult
life it was 32 bits.
And recently Intel and AMD
have gone to 64-bit processors.
But 64 bits ain't
near enough if you
want to do what's called high
precision computation, you want
to find precisely the
weight of a neutrino,
if you're a physicist,
for example.
And that, you're talking
about literally a hundred
decimal digits,
which is obviously
much more than 64 bits.
And that's just one example.
So what happens if you want to
compute the square root of 2
to a million digits, or
pi to 10 million digits?
How do you do that
on a computer?
So that's what we're going
to do for this module, which
is a short module on numerics.
We'll have a lecture today
and another one on Tuesday
telling you about techniques
that use, among other things,
Newton's method to compute
irrational numbers, as one
example, to arbitrary precision
And for your problem set
you are you going to look at
different application that
corresponds to encryption,
RSA encryption,
where you have to
work with primes.
These are now integers,
but you work with primes
that are thousands of
bits long, so again,
much more than 64 bits.
And so you have to
think about how you're
going to multiply numbers
that are thousands of bits
long, how you're going to divide
numbers that are thousands
of bits long, and that's really
the purpose of this module.
So let's start off by
talking about irrationals.
And Pythagoras, whom I'm
sure you've all heard of
is credited with the discovery
that a square's diagonal
and its side are
incommensurable.
So you can't really express
the ratio as a rational number,
as a ratio of integers.
Now it turns out that the
Babylonians and the Indians
knew this way before
Pythagoras, but he
gets credit for the
Pythagoras theorem.
And there's also a
Greek philosopher,
in fact, maybe he was first
a philosopher and then
a mathematician, and he
the espoused a philosophy
that, I guess, is called
Pythagorean mysticism, that
said that all is number, so
the world is about numbers.
And he worshipped numbers, his
followers worshipped numbers.
And the problem here was
that he didn't really
like the square root of 2
because he couldn't express it
as a number, of what he thought
of as a number, which was 1, 2,
3, et cetera, integers,
whole numbers.
So he called this
ratio speechless,
something that he
really couldn't explain.
And irrationals were
actually considered a threat
to the mystics because
they couldn't really
explain what square
root of 2 was.
They'd try and measure
it, and they would come up
with the right answer because
the next time around it
would be a little bit
different If they did things
a little more precisely,
or not so precisely.
And it bothered them no end.
And so they tried to find
patterns in irrationals
because they considered
them a threat.
And they obviously
didn't find patterns,
but imagine if we could
actually find patterns.
I mean, that would
be a really big deal,
it would be better than p equals
np, if you know what I mean.
If you don't it doesn't matter.
So that's another of motivation
for high precision arithmetic.
Let's try and find
patterns in irrationals
if you go to millions
and trillions of digits,
maybe it's just a matter of time
before we discover that there's
no such thing as
irrational numbers.
Who knows?
So let's do that for the
rest of this lecture.
Let's try and
figure out how we're
going to compute irrational
numbers, or things
like square root of 2,
to arbitrary precision.
So we can go play around,
and we'll give you some code,
and you can play with it.
So if you look at
square root of 2--
I'll just put this up
here-- so it's 1.414,
you probably all know that.
Then it's 213,562,373,095,048
et cetera.
I mean, I don't see
a pattern there.
I see a zero, a
couple of zeroes here.
It's hard to imagine--
you'd probably
want to think of a computer
program that generates
square root of 2, and then
maybe a different computer
program that's
looking for patterns.
So let's not worry about
the square root of 2.
I want to digress a little bit.
I did say this was a bit of
a recreational mathematics
lecture.
And let's talk about something
completely different,
which are Catalan numbers.
So these are really my
favorite numbers in the world.
And people like primes, some
people like irrationals,
I like Catalan numbers.
Catalan numbers are-- they
show up all over the place.
How many of you know
what Catalan numbers are?
Oh good.
Excellent.
So Catalan numbers have
a recursive definition.
You can think of them as
representing the cardinality
of the set p of balanced
parentheses strings.
And we're going to
recursively define
these strings as follows.
We're going to have
lambda belonging
to p where lambda
is the empty string.
And that's rule one.
Rule two is if alpha
and beta belong
to p then I'm going to put
a paren, open paren, alpha,
close paren, and then beta.
And that belongs to p.
So you iteratively or
recursively apply this rule
over and over, and
you start getting
strings that are balanced.
So this is balanced.
Now that's not
balanced, this is not
balanced, and so
on and so forth.
Obviously things
get more complicated
in terms of the parentheses
if when you have more brackets
or parentheses.
And so, the nice thing
about this definition
is that you can get every
non-empty balanced paren
string, via rule two, from
a unique alpha, beta pair.
So as an example,
suppose you want
to generate the string
that looks like this--
So that's a little more
complicated than the strings
that we have looked
at so far-- then you
obtain that by having alpha
be this simple string.
And then you put the brackets
around that, and then
your beta corresponds to this.
So now alpha and beta
were previously generated,
so if you applied rule
two to the empty string,
with alpha being
the empty string
and beta being the empty string,
then you get this thing here.
And obviously you could
get beta by setting
alpha to be the empty string and
beta to be this string that you
just generated, and
so on and so forth.
So you just keep going and the
strings get longer and longer.
The cardinality of the set
gets bigger and bigger.
And those of the
Catalan numbers.
OK
And so, this is a
non-trivial question,
which is I'd like to
enumerate the Catalan numbers,
and compute, and get
an analytical form
for the cardinality of the set.
And that's really what
the Catalan number is.
It's a cardinality of the set.
And so cn is the number of
balanced parentheses strings
with exactly n pairs
of parentheses.
And I have c0 equals 1,
which is my base case.
And that's just setting--
it's an empty string.
I'm going to say that
empty string is a string,
and that's just setting
up the base case.
And now I want an
equation for cn plus 1.
And I need to use
the fact that I
can get cn plus 1, a
particular strain that belongs
to this set, where I have n plus
1 parenthesis in a unique way
from a string I've previously
generated that was part
of either the set that
had n parentheses--
or it was combined using
strings, where alpha was
in some set that was
maybe generated awhile
back with a small
n, or something
significantly smaller than
n, and another thing that
was generated, beta,
that was generated later,
or maybe at the same
time, et cetera.
So can someone tell me what an
equation would be for cn plus 1
based on the cis
that are less than n?
So what about c1?
Maybe I'll ask-- what about c1?
What's c1?
1.
c1 is 1 because all I have
is this string, that's
the only balanced string.
Now I have c0 and c1.
What's an equation for
c2 in terms of numbers.
I want a number for
c2 based on c0 and c1.
Someone?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: C0 plus c1.
PROFESSOR: c0 plus c1?
No, not quite right.
How many strings do I have?
c0 plus c1.
Yeah, actually you're right.
Well, the number is right
but the equation is wrong.
It's not quite that.
You get a-- Yup.
AUDIENCE: So when something
like c-- c1 times c1 plus c1.
PROFESSOR: c1 times c1 plus c1?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
PROFESSOR: I think
you want to use a c0.
AUDIENCE: OK. c0.
PROFESSOR: c0 Well, that's
not quite right either.
Someone else.
Yeah.
OK.
You.
AUDIENCE: c0 times c1
plus c1 [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: c0
times c1-- c2 would
be c0 times c1 plus c1 times c0.
OK.
And if you're setting the
alpha-- So here's the thing,
you set the alpha, and
you choose the alpha,
and then you choose the beta.
And there's a couple
of different ways
that you could choose the alpha.
You could choose
the alpha from-- you
could make it a
string that's empty,
or you could make
it the one string
that you've generated
so far, which
is the standard simple
string, the non-empty,
the non-trivial balanced string.
And you could do that in
a couple different ways
with alpha.
And that's why you have
two terms over there.
So the number, in terms of
all of the equations I got,
they all came out
to be the same.
It's 2, and that's correct.
But this is the equation for it.
And so now, tell me
what a general equation
is for cn plus 1
based on what we've
learned so far for
the c2 equation?
Yeah, back to you.
AUDIENCE: So c0 times
cn plus c1 times cn
minus 1 all the way to
cn times [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Perfect.
Good.
That deserves a cushion.
That wasn't me, it was you.
And put it right
there, breadbasket.
So cn plus 1 equals sigma,
so you give me a summation,
k equals 0 through n,
ck, cn minus k where
n is greater than or equal to 0.
And you can figure this out,
it's not particularly important
as to exactly why this is true.
You can think about it offline.
But the interesting thing is
that this is a generator of,
obviously, and it's
going to give you
a nice looking set of numbers.
And I came in early and wrote
that the Catalan in numbers
up on the board going from
c0, c1, c2, et cetera, just
in case-- just in case you ever
see these numbers in real life,
or when you're writing
computer programs.
Or you're driving on the road,
the next time you see a license
plate 4862, turn around and
tell your mom or dad, hey,
that's the Catalan number.
And maybe she'll be impressed.
This, of course,
you're not going
to see on a license
plate, but you can always
make up a bumper
sticker or something,
and you can have
the c17 as being
a bumper sticker on your car.
I mean, that's the kind
of thing that I'd do.
Anyway, so it's just in
case you see these numbers--
we might come back to this a
little bit later in the class,
but--
AUDIENCE: 42 is on that list.
PROFESSOR: 42 is on that list.
Yeah, it has to be.
42 is on every list.
42 is the answer
to every question.
I am glad you guys didn't
put 42 down in the answer
to every quiz question.
It doesn't quite work
all the time, all right,
but most of the time
42 is a good answer.
Most of the time.
OK good.
So let's get down to business.
So we talked about Catalan
numbers as a digression.
If you see them you'll
recognize them, I think.
Let's talk about how
we could compute.
Let's go back to
irrationals and talk
about how we could
compute square root of 2
and other things to
arbitrary precision.
So what I want to do is to
talk about Newton's method.
And Newton's method is
something you probably
learned about in middle
school, high school.
And let's say you
have a function
y equals f of x where
this is x and that's
y, the coordinate axes.
And we want to try and find
the root of fx equals 0
through successive
approximation.
For example, we might have f
of x equals x squared minus a.
And if a is 2 then you're
trying to use Newton's method
to find the root,
and you're going
to end up trying to compute
square root of 2 or plus
minus square root
of 2, in this case.
But you can go for
a particular root,
and you're try and
converge to that.
So the way Newton's method
works is it tries, geometrically
speaking, it tries
to find tangents--
and a different color
chalk would be useful here
but I don't seem to see
one-- So what would happen
is, let's say you
are sitting out here,
and it's successive
approximation method,
so this would give you x of i.
And now you want to
compute x of i plus 1.
And what you're going
to do is draw a tangent,
like so, and find the
intercept onto the x-axis,
the x-intercept.
And that is going to
be your xi plus 1.
And you have to write an
equation for that tangent.
And this is, I guess,
trying to figure
out how much of middle school
math or high school math
that you remember.
What is the equation
for that tangent?
Anybody?
The equation for that tangent?
What do you do in order
to compute that tangent?
Give me a name.
AUDIENCE: Derivative?
PROFESSOR: Derivative.
Thank you.
So what's the equation
for that tangent?
y equals-- Someone?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: It's a good
think your middle school,
high school teachers
aren't here.
Not you.
You already got a cushion.
Someone else.
All right.
I'll start giving
you some hints here.
f of xi plus-- plus--
ALL: f prime.
PROFESSOR: f prime xi.
Thank you.
All right.
You get a cushion.
I'm getting them.
Whatever it takes.
Here you go.
Yeah.
That was left-handed,
by the way.
I'm actually
right-handed, as you know.
So what do we have here?
So we have f prime xi.
Now come on, let's
finish it, finish it.
AUDIENCE: Times i minus xi.
PROFESSOR: Times xi is xi.
Thank you.
OK.
So now I get it.
You thought this was
too simple a question.
You guys were insulted
by the question.
So that's why you didn't tell
me what it was At least, that's
what I'm going to pretend
to make myself feel better.
So y equals f of
xi plus f prime xi,
which is the derivative
of f evaluated at xi times
x minus xi, that's the
equation for the line.
And that's essentially
what we have
to do to compute things
like square root of 2, which
is iteratively applied
Newton's method.
The only problem is this
is all good in theory
that we can do-- take that
equation turn it into xi
plus 1 equals xi minus f of
xi divided by f prime of xi.
And if you end up doing f of x
equals x squared minus a, then
you have xi plus 1
equals xi minus xi
squared minus a divided by 2xi,
which is the derivative of x
squared minus a evaluated at xi.
And finally you get
this equation, xi
plus a divided by
xi divided by 2.
So it's fairly straightforward.
xi plus 1 equals xi plus a
divided by xi divided by 2.
And if you look
at this, remember
that a is typically
a small number.
I mean, it's two, in
this case, if you're
computing square root of 2.
it may even be an
integer, maybe a fraction.
But you have to do
a division here.
And remember that since
we want to compute things
to millions of digits,
potentially, these numbers,
the xi numbers, are going
to have millions of digits.
And so if you end up
running this Newton method
on a equals 2, then
if I simulate what
happens without worrying
about the implementation,
and this is what you'll get.
You have x0-- you start with x0
equals 1 with a bunch of zeros.
xi equals 1.5 with a
bunch of zeros, et cetera.
And then, x2 equals
1.41666 et cetera.
That goes on.
And we're not talking
about fractions here,
we're talking about
floating point numbers that
are integers with a certain
amount of precision.
So you've decided that
you want to compute this
to d digits of precision
where d may be a million.
And so, really, here you would
have a representation that's
a million digits
long that where,
basically, everything is zero,
and here everything but one
is 0, or maybe a couple
if you count the 1 here.
And here you have
all these sixes here,
and so on and so forth.
And you keep going, and you
get x2 equals 1.414215686.
And I want to write
one more because I
want to point out
something that's important.
1.414213562.
And what's nice about
this, if you go compare it
with what you have
up there, is that you
have quadratic convergence
using the Newton's method.
And what do I mean by that?
Well, quadratic convergence
is a nice property.
It's much better than
linear convergence.
Linear convergence
would mean that you
get an extra digit of
precision for every iteration.
So in this case, actually,
a quadratic is better.
Usually we think of
quadratic algorithms,
and we are going to throw up.
But linear algorithms
is what we like.
But in this case it's
actually a good thing.
You have this extended this
quadratic rate of convergence
where the number of
digits that are correct
doubles with every
iteration, as you can see.
So here you have-- you
start with, roughly,
if you rounded this
up you would get 5.
So you're saying that that's
one digit of precision
in terms of the decimal.
And then, now you're
talking about 41421356,
so that's 1, 2,
3, 4, 5, 6, 7, 8,
so that's eight digits of
precision here, four here,
and so on and so forth.
So that's nice.
That's why the Newton's
method is actually
used in practice because the
number of digits doubles.
This is a precision.
So now you don't get too
scared about calculating things
that are a million because
you kind of go and say, whoa,
I mean, that's not
so bad, that's only
a logarithmic number
of integrations.
And it's not like you have to
run for a million iterations.
You go 2, 4, 8, 16, and now
that exponential helps you,
the geometric series helps you.
So that's the nice thing
about the Newton's method.
Haven't quite told
you how we are
going to compute the
most important thing here
with respect to a divided by xi.
So this is just additions.
You can imagine that if
you have long numbers
you'd end up doing addition
fairly straightforwardly
because you only have to
worry about one carry,
and so you go off.
And I'm sure you've
added up numbers
that are in tens, if not
hundreds, of digits long
but I'm guessing
you haven't manually
multiplied numbers that are
hundreds of digits long.
And if you have
I'd be impressed,
though I won't
believe your result.
But that's something that is
kind of a painful thing to do.
And so that's why
we need computers.
And that's multiplication
and-- has anybody
divided a hundred-digit number
by another 50-digit number?
No.
So you need computers.
So we've got to be able
to do that division there,
a divided by xi,
using computers.
And so that's really the purpose
of this and the next lecture
If you're only going
to do a high precision
multiplication here.
And try see what an algorithm
would be for high precision
multiplication because
what we're going to do
is, essentially, take the
reciprocal of one over xi
and then multiply that by a.
And we need-- division is going
to require multiplication.
You don't really
see a multiplication
there other than
a times 1 over xi.
And you can say, well, do we
really need multiplication?
Well, the answer is
the division algorithm
that is used in practice in
most division algorithms have
multiplication as a subroutine.
So we're going to have to
figure out high precision
multiplication first--
It's a little bit easier
than division-- and use it as
a subroutine for high precision
division, which
we'll do next time.
So now we're sort of back
in 006 land, if you will.
We have a problem that is
high precision multiplication,
and we want to find
an algorithm for it.
And there's the
vanilla algorithm
that is going to take
certain amounts of time,
asymptotically
speaking, and then there
is better and better algorithms.
As you can imagine,
multiplication
is just such a
fundamental operation
that people have
looked at trying
to reduce the complexity of
high precision multiplication.
So if you have n bits-- So
what is the standard algorithm
for multiplication take if
you have n bits of precision?
AUDIENCE: N squared.
PROFESSOR: n squared.
But you can do better.
And the people are work on it.
You can do fast
Fourier transforms.
We won't quite do that here.
If you take 6.046 you'll
probably learn about that.
But we'll do a
couple of algorithms
that are better than the
order n squared method,
and we'll do one of those today.
So the way they're going
to work with integers--
one little point that I need to
make before we move ahead here
is, generally, we going to
say, for the purposes of 006,
that we know the digits of
precision up front because we
want d digits of precision,
maybe it's 42, maybe it's 125.
In the case of our problem
set in RSA we going to have it
1,024-bit numbers, maybe 2,048.
So we know d beforehand.
And so what we want
is an integer, which
is 10 raised to d times the
square root of 2, a floor,
and which is essentially the
same as that, 2 times 10 raised
to 2 d.
So we're going to treat
these as integers,
so we don't want to worry
about decimal points
and things like that.
All of these things are
going to be integers.
And there's no problem here.
We can still use
Newton's method.
It just works on integers.
And let's take a
look at how we would
apply Newton's method
in standard form.
And we won't to
really get to the part
where we're going to go from
division to multiplication
today, as I said,
we're just going
to look at how you can
multiply two numbers.
So I didn't mean
to say that we're
going to look at
Newton's method.
We're going to look at high
precision multiplication,
and then, eventually,
we're going
to use that to build
Newton's method
which requires the division.
So I have two n-digit
numbers, and the radix
could be-- the base
could be 2, 10.
Normally, it doesn't
really matter.
0 less than x, less than
y, strictly less than r
raised to n.
That's standard for the ranges.
And what I have
here is-- the way
I'm going to do this is use
our favorite strategy, which
is divide and conquer, because
I have n, which is large,
need to break things
down, break it into n
by two-digit multiplications.
And when, finally,
I break things down,
I get down to 64 bits, I
just run one instruction
on my computer to multiply
the 64-bit numbers.
And the standard machines, you
would get 128 bits of result
back when you multiply
64-bit numbers.
So in some sense
you only go down--
you don't go down to 1
bit, you go down to 64
and your machine does the rest.
So what we have here
is you set x to be x1
where x1 is the high half, r
raised to n over 2 plus x0.
So x1 is the more significant
half and x0 is the low half.
And the same thing for y.
y1, whoops, r raised
to n over 2 plus y0.
Now the ranges change.
x0 and x1 are smaller, so that's
what you have for x0 and x1.
Same thing for y0 and y1.
So that's a fairly
straightforward decomposition
of this multiplication
operation.
And again, if you do things
in a straightforward way
you will create a recursive
multiply, as I'll write here.
And what you do is you say
let z0 equal x0 times y0,
z two equals x2 times
y2, and-- I missed z1,
but z1 equals x0, y1 plus x1 y0.
And I have, overall,
z equals y equals
x1 y1 times r raised to n
plus x0 y1 plus x1 y0 times
r raised to n over
2 plus x0 y0 zero.
And this part here was
z0, this part here was z1,
and this part here was z2.
And if you look at, it you need
four multiplies, 1, 2, 3, 4.
And you need four
multiplies of n
by two-- n by two-digit numbers.
And by now, after you have
prepared for quiz two,
I will just say that it would
take theta n square time
because you're
recursive equation
is tn equals 4t of n over 2 plus
the linear time that you take
for addition.
So this is tn equals 4t
of n over 2 plus theta n.
And you're assuming
that the additions here
take linear time.
So that's how you get your
theta n square algorithm.
And we're not happy with that.
We'd like to do better.
And so how do you do better?
Well, there's many
ways of doing better.
The simplest way off fairly,
substantially lowering
the complexity is
due to a gentleman
by the name of Karatsuba.
This is one of
those things where
if you were born
early enough you
get your name on an algorithm.
And what happens here is, using
the z's that I have out there,
you essentially say, look,
I know z0 equals x0 and y0,
I'm going to go
ahead and multiply.
z2 equals x2 and y2,
go ahead and do that.
And now I'm going to write
z1 as x0 plus x1 times y0
plus y1 minus z0 minus z2.
So you're actually
computing z0 and z2 first,
and then using
them to compute z1.
So someone tell me why
this is interesting?
And just take it all the way to
the complexity of an algorithm.
Explain to me why
this is interesting
and why Karatsuba's algorithm
has-- I'll give it away--
a lower complexity
than theta n square?
But tell me what it is.
Someone?
Someone other than you.
Someone way at the back.
Yup.
Out there.
AUDIENCE: It's n to
the log base 2 of 3.
PROFESSOR: n raised to--
AUDIENCE: Log base 2--
PROFESSOR: --log base 2 of 3.
That's exactly right.
And now, why did you get that?
Explain to me how you got there.
AUDIENCE: If you're
using three products--
PROFESSOR: That's right.
So first insight
is that we're only
doing three
multiplications here.
Additions are easy.
And we're doing three
multiplications as opposed
to four.
So tell me how that
equation changed, of tn.
tn equals--
AUDIENCE: 3 [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: 3 times t of
n over 2 plus theta n
because you're doing three
multiplications rather than
four.
Multiplications are the
complicated operation.
Divisions are even
more complicated,
but additions are easy, and you
could do those in linear time
for n-digit numbers.
And so, if you do that and
then you go off and you say,
well, that tells
us that tn equals
theta of n raised to log two
of three, which is, by the way,
theta of n raised to
1.58, roughly speaking.
And I do not want to compute
that to arbitrary precision,
though I could.
But that goes on and on.
Why don't you grab
this after you're done.
But that just goes on and on.
1.58 is a rough approximation.
That's an irrational
number too, assuming
you think that
irrational numbers exist.
That's an irrational number.
So good, that's
really all I had.
By the way, it's 1.58490625.
I really should have
written that down.
1.58-- in the context
of this lecture
I think it's
important that we get
at least a few
digits a precision.
Now you can imagine that you
could do it better than this.
And it turns out that--
we'll talk a little bit
about this next time-- But you
can imagine breaking this up
into not n over two chunks,
but n over three chunks.
Why don't I just break
up x into the top third,
the middle third, and
then the bottom third,
and then try and see
if I can get away
with fewer than eight
multiplications?
Because the original
thing would have
taken eight, and if I
can do less than eight,
maybe I can reduce
that 1.58 number.
So that's a little
bit of a preview
for what we'll do next time.
But what I'd like
to do is do a demo.
And I want you to run
that-- it's out there so
blank that out for a second.
What I'd like to do is really
look at a different problem
than square root of 2, and
show you a demo of code
that Victor wrote that computes
this particular quantity that,
you would argue, is irrational,
to arbitrary digits.
Though we'll probably only go
up to about a thousand today.
And if we just look at-- root
2 is kind of boring, right?
It's been around for a while.
Let's go back and remember
high school geometry.
So I think your
high school teachers
would like this lecture.
Nice little review.
So what is that about?
That's supposed to be a circle,
I think, as you've forgotten.
That's supposed to be a circle.
And the circle here is
a really big circle.
It's a trillion units long.
I'm into big numbers
today, big numbers.
And the center of the
circle is c, c for center.
That is what's called a radius,
in case you'd forgotten.
And that's b.
And this is also a
radius, and that's a.
And what I'm going
to do is I'm going--
I want to make a drop a little,
I guess, perpendicular down,
which is one unit high.
So the way that
this is structured
is that this is one unit
high, this obviously
is-- someone tell
me what that is, CB.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Half a trillion.
That's half a trillion.
And obviously, CA
is half a trillion.
And if I call this
D, somebody who
remembers high school or
middle school geometry
give me an equation for AD.
And that's definitely
worth a cushion.
so what's an
equation for AD guys?
Yeah.
Go ahead.
AUDIENCE: The radius,
half-trillion minus the square
root of--
PROFESSOR: Square
root of-- Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Minus the square root
of [INAUDIBLE] square minus 1?
PROFESSOR: Perfect, perfect.
OK good.
So AD equals AC
minus CD, and that
is going to be half a
trillion-- that is 500 billion,
a little bit less
than bailout money,
but it's close-- 500 thousand
minus square root of 500--
this, when you start
squaring this, of course,
is not even real,
real big money.
But 500 thousand
squared minus 1.
So forget the
square root of two.
You can put the screen down.
So is it on, the projector?
AUDIENCE: It's on, it
just needs a [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: OK.
You can turn that on.
AUDIENCE: Rolling.
PROFESSOR: So what
we're going to do
is, I'm just going to
show you the digits
of this crazy quantity being
computed to tens of thousands
of digits.
And you argue that this
is it something clearly
that isn't a perfect square.
You took a perfect square,
subtracted 1 from it,
and so you have an
irrational quantity
that is going to go on and on.
And let's see what that
number-- what it looks like.
OK?
Get out of the way.
I hope you can
see from the back.
AUDIENCE: Oh man, really?
PROFESSOR: Looking pretty good
so far, looking pretty good.
AUDIENCE: That's crazy.
PROFESSOR: Somebody see
the numbers somewhere else?
Have you see these
numbers before?
Like 20 minutes ago, like
right in front of you?
OK All right.
So I think that's a
good place to stop.
If you want an
explanation for this
I think you can go
to section tomorrow.
I'm going to use a some
attendance tomorrow.
All right.
Happy to answer questions
about the rest of the lecture,
and thanks for coming.